le retour de renault avec un boucan
d'enfer le titre de son nouvel album le
chanteur absente pendant sept ans
revient avec des chansons bouleversante
où il parle surtout de sa propre
souffrance
sabine gorny dans le solitude de silence
de souffrance 50 piges 12 millions
d'albums au compteur renault éternel
poulbot soudain mal dans son perfecto
coeur en billette lui l'amoureux d'une
seule gonzesses sa domino l'amour se
fait la malle séparation des pressions
renault loin des studios se réfugient
dans les bistrots à 40 ans bien sûr
j'ai peur cuisine ne soit perdu
jamais
je
avant
et puis un jour au fond d'un bistrot le
sursaut retour d'inspiration une chanson
puis 13 autres pour cicatriser le mal
d'aimer journal de bord des années
noires petit bijou d'émotion
renault a vaincu ses démons premier
gainsbourg 15 pareil alors le rhône
whitelaw
rocard bureau ricard un côté blanc teint
rouge et noir personne n'est tout moche
tout moitié angers moitié [ __ ]
et c'est ce que nous allons voir
les douleurs les bleus à l'âme c'est
beau mais ça fait mal renault fatigué de
se révolter de s'engager de dénoncer
excepté dans ce duo avec axelle red sur
la tragédie du 11 septembre de cinq
revenus
deux anonymes
tél
renous désabusé tout a changé depuis les
années 80 quand ce titi parisien
rebelles chantait en verlan la france
des banlieues des potes et des hlm puis
un regard est comme ça les boîtes grands
modèles de bottes
exit donc le chanteur énervant place au
gavroche émouvant entre chagrin et
loiriens renoux a trouvé sa voie celle
des mots bouleversant pour dire ses
tourments son côté tous les filles
se moque du tiers